[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
estamos con olex y Danny Love Secretario
del Consejo de Seguridad y defensa de
Ucrania una de las principales
instituciones que coordinan la
resistencia ucraniana ante la agresión
rusa señor muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros nos encontramos en un momento
en el que Ucrania dice que necesita
urgentemente más armas de sus aliados
occidentales para defenderse de posibles
nuevos ataques rusos a comienzos de la
primavera y para poder montar su propia
contra ofensiva me gustaría empezar
preguntándole qué cosas están cambiando
en el nivel de apoyo de occidente a
Ucrania
hemos demostrado que todos los servicios
de inteligencia incluidos los franceses
se equivocaron cuando predijeron que
Rusia podría derrotarnos en 357 días
le demostramos a todo el mundo que eso
no Sería posible que no pasaría después
de eso los países empezaron a ayudarnos
un poco
ahora el mito del segundo ejército más
poderoso del mundo se ha desvanecido
como la niebla matutina la cantidad de
países que nos ayudan crece cada semana
Cómo ve la evolución de la situación en
las próximas semanas y meses
será difícil Lo que sucede es que Putin
y su grupo ahora piensan que no pueden
perder y no quieren admitir sus errores
y por supuesto tratarán de hacer todo lo
posible por cambiar el curso de esta
guerra
sabemos para lo que se están preparando
Nosotros también estamos preparando
nuestra resistencia sabemos dónde van a
querer centrar los ataques y nos estamos
preparando para eso puedo decirle con
seguridad que esta guerra se resolverá
en el campo de batalla
podría describirnos Cómo se imagina el
mejor y el peor de los escenarios en el
futuro
se refiere al final de la guerra bueno
la victoria para nosotros significaría
que nuestro país vuelve a tener las
fronteras de 1991
No necesitamos el territorio de alguien
más y no le daremos el nuestro a nadie
no pensamos en los peores escenarios
lucharemos y haremos todo lo posible
para asegurarnos de recuperar nuestro
territorio conforme a las fronteras de
1991 todas las otras ideas que varios
países han empezado a manifestar como la
necesidad de darle a Putin una especie
de garantías de hacer un acuerdo con él
de no provocarlo son absolutamente
inaceptables para nosotros
si hubieran empezado a enviarnos grandes
cantidades de armas en marzo creo que
todo esto ya se habría acabado Cuanto
más pronto recibamos ayuda
pronto podremos resolver este problema
lo repito creer que es posible llegar a
un acuerdo con el régimen fascista de
Putin no es realista de ninguna manera
puedo darle un ejemplo de la historia
reciente
en 2008 cuando pasó lo que pasó en
Georgia el presidente francés participó
en los diálogos entre el líder georgiano
y Putin llegaron a un acuerdo
no cumplió una sola palabra de lo que se
había acordado no es posible hacer
acuerdos con alguien que no cumple su
palabra
estaba pensando en los plazos
los plazos dependen de la entrega de las
armas y de muchos otros factores la
pregunta sobre cuándo empezará el
proceso de colapso y desintegración de
Rusia es solo una cuestión de tiempo
poco tiempo en términos históricos y eso
no es culpa nuestra
el colapso de Rusia es obra de Putin el
resultado de todo lo que él ha estado en
ese país durante los últimos 23 años
será la desintegración de la federación
rusa él es el destructor de la
federación rusa
ni siquiera los grandes países pueden
imponer sus condiciones sobre el
territorio de otros países
miren por ejemplo a Estados Unidos
cuando se fueron de Vietnam habían
entendido que de ninguna manera podrían
derrotar militarmente a los vietnamitas
la decencia de irse ahora Rusia debe
hacer lo mismo cuanto antes se vaya a
Rusia de Ucrania mejores serán sus
posibilidades de sobrevivir de una
manera más o menos aceptable
mi impresión es que en occidente algunos
quizás piensan tal vez de manera cínica
y sin decirlo explícitamente que es
mejor una guerra larga en Ucrania que se
prolongue en vez de que Putin entre en
pánico y utilice armas nucleares
que contestaría eso
por supuesto esas opiniones existen y
ciertos países y ciertos grupos entre
los líderes políticos creen que esa es
la manera de hacer las cosas
pero no Hay que tenerle miedo a Putin
si uno empieza a tener miedo y se deja
invadir por ese miedo empieza a perder
uno pierde si cae en el miedo y el
pánico
asustar a los países con armas nucleares
Es simplemente inaceptable
Hay que tenerle miedo él nunca
presionará el botón nuclear es
simplemente un cobarde
porque está tan seguro de eso
mire antes de la guerra mucho
representantes de servicios de
inteligencia extranjeros se reunieron
conmigo en esta misma sala para hablar
sobre lo que estaba pasando
todos estaban seguros de que íbamos a
perder yo les expliqué que eso no era
posible les dije que entendíamos muy
bien a los rusos que sabíamos Cómo iban
a pensar y cómo se iban a comportar en
una situación determinada
Dios no lo quiere tomar a semejante
decisión en media hora Rusia llegaría a
su fin Rusia dejaría de existir ni
siquiera sería necesario responder con
un simplemente quedarían destruidos y
todas las personas pensadas en Rusia lo
entienden Putin no presionará el botón
nuclear no lo hará
Cirilo el patriarca de Moscú dijo la
derrota de Rusia sería el fin del mundo
alguien en Rusia también dijo mejor que
no exista nadie que Rusia deje de
existir es un poco como lo que ocurrió
con los nazis cuando terminó la Segunda
Guerra Mundial que se suicidaron no cree
que eso sea posible en este caso nuclear
no no tenía armas nucleares
nadie aunque la hubiera tenido nunca
habrían permitido que lo hiciera no
dejarán que puti presiona el botón
nuclear no lo harán
hay que tener eso presente
eso es lo primero
lo segundo es que el ejército ruso
actualmente está en tal estado que la
explosión que estaría tratando de
provocar podría ocurrir justo donde está
ubicado lo vemos con los cohetes que
siguen disparando hacia nuestro
territorio
algunos aterrizan en territorio ruso no
lo dicen pero lo sabemos
la región de volgogrado la región de
saratov la región de kurs justamente
quería preguntarle acerca de las
situaciones en Rusia
cree que Ucrania debería estar
disparando a su objetivo en Rusia y
están los aliados occidentales de
Ucrania disuadiéndola de hacerlo
no estamos librando una guerra en
territorio ruso
plimea es nuestro territorio y
pelearemos por él las regiones de
nuestro territorio y pelearemos por
ellas
Punto Final proyección
de belgorote en Rusia ponen armas que
matan a nuestros niños
tenemos que destruir esas armas
que quiten las armas que matan a
nuestros niños de ahí y nos detendremos
su región de procedencia está en
contacto con alguien de allí
sí soy de lugans no les gusta decirlo
fui alcalde de fui gobernador de la
región
los rusos creen que todas las personas
que viven en la región de lugans
deberían ser consideradas rusas
y eso no me impide ser un patriota
ucraniano
hay muchas personas como yo que siguen
ahí
quienes están ayudando en Nuestro camino
hacia la victoria
qué es lo que más lo ha sorprendido o
impresionado en el curso de estos
últimos 11 meses de guerra
realmente no he estado sorprendido e
impresionado recibí la confirmación de
la grandeza de nuestro pueblo
ya
estaba seguro de eso y después del 24 de
febrero esa seguridad alcanzó el más
alto de los niveles
hace poco usted escribió que en un nuevo
mundo un estado terrorista debe ser
expulsado del Consejo de Seguridad de
las Naciones Unidas y despojado de sus
armas nucleares
Cómo cree exactamente que sea posible
hacer eso
no hay nada imposible en este mundo
el mundo debería entender que si un país
es terrorista no tiene un puesto en el
consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas
al menos mientras dure Mire qué
deberíamos haber hecho
En mi opinión apenas empezó la guerra el
24 de febrero
Rusia debería haber sido suspendida del
Consejo de Seguridad
al menos la guerra eso habría sido lo
más justo
en vez de cubrirnos los ojos y pretender
que no está pasando nada y seguir
viviendo Mira Putin no cumple las reglas
no respeta ningún acuerdo internacional
el mundo realmente quiere poder convivir
con él siguiendo las reglas Pero eso no
funciona si uno se sienta a jugar
ajedrez
hay ciertas reglas el caballo se mueve
de una manera el Peón de otra
jugar ajedrez con él diga todas las
piezas al suelo y dice
Esa es la situación actual el presidente
dice que quiere ir a las Naciones Unidas
precisamente el 24 de febrero es para
pedir que Rusia sea expulsado del
Consejo de Seguridad todos los países
civilizados del Mundo deberían estar
pidiendo eso si hablamos de países
civilizados
si hablamos de países a los que solo les
importa el dinero y lo que pueden
obtener de los recursos rusos Pues que
se lo digan al mundo que la democracia
la libertad una comunidad internacional
basada en reglas son absolutamente
irrelevantes y que debemos vivir bajo
otras reglas
tenemos que decidir
o construimos un mundo democrático un
mundo libre en el que los individuos son
los elementos clave de la Democracia
o apoyamos a los terroristas que en
cualquier momento pueden decidir
destruir un país u otro simplemente
diciendo que así son las cosas
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y gracias a ustedes por su
sintonía quédense en France 24 Para más
información
[Música]